So we have just seen
that a clever trick based
on the frequency interpretation
of the transitions
between successive
states, like here,
allows us to write a simple
set of equations which
can be solved recursively,
given here, giving pi i plus 1
as a function of pi of i.
More specifically,
we have pi i plus 1
equals pi of i times p of i.
Divide by q of i plus 1.
And this is true for
i equal 0 up to m.
And to start the recursion,
we need to find pi of 0.
And this can be done using this
normalization condition-- which
leads to pi of 0 times 1 plus
p0 over q1 plus et cetera
equals 1.
Let's illustrate the
details of this procedure
on a special case.
Let's assume that all
the p's are the same
and all the q's are the same.
So this is a special case
in which we are interested.
So at each point in time, if
we are somewhere in the middle,
you have probability
p of moving up,
and probability
q of moving down.
Define rho to be the
ratio of p over q.
Rho can be interpreted as
the frequency of going up
versus the frequency
of going down.
If it's a service system,
you can think of it
as a measure of how
loaded the system is.
If p equals q, that means that
if you are at this state--
you are equally likely
to move left or right.
So the chain does
not have a tendency
to move in that direction
or in that direction.
If rho is bigger than 1,
so that p is bigger than q,
it means that whenever we are
at some state in the middle,
we are more likely to
move right, as opposed
to moving left.
Which means that the
chain has a tendency
to move in that direction.
And if you think of this as a
number of customers in queue,
it means your system has the
tendency to become loaded
and to build up a queue.
So rho being bigger
than 1 corresponds
to a heavy load,
where queues build up.
Rho less than one
corresponds to the system
where queues have the
tendency to drain down.
The system is going to
move in that direction.
Now let us write
down these equations
for that special case.
We end up with that,
which is pi i times rho,
by definition of rho.
Once you look at this equation,
you realize that pi of 1
is pi of 0 times rho.
And pi of 2 is pi of
1 times rho equals
pi of 0 times rho square.
And so on and so forth.
And you find that you
can express pi of i
as pi of 0 times
rho at the power
i for any possible
i between 0 and m.
And now if we use the
normalization condition,
we get that pi of 0
times 1 plus rho plus rho
squared plus rho at the
power m is equal to 1.
Let's now complete
the calculations
for two special cases.
If rho is equal to 1,
that means p equals q.
Then pi i equals
pi of 0 for all i.
It means that all the steady
state probabilities are equal.
This special case is called
a symmetric random walk.
So you start at the
state at a point in time.
Either you stay in place, or
you have an equal probability
of going left or right.
There is no bias in
either direction.
You might think that
in such a process,
you will tend to
get stuck either
near one end or the other end.
It turns out that
no, in the long run,
the symmetric random
walk is equally likely
to be at any of those states.
And for the special case--
this equation here-- is simply
that pi of 0 times
1 plus m equals one.
That means that pi of 0
equals 1 over 1 plus m.
Which is consistent
with the fact
that all steady-state
probabilities are the same.
They are all equally likely.
They are end states.
And so each one of them, pi i
is pi of 0, which is 1 over 1
plus m.
The Markov chain
is equally likely
to be in any of these m plus
1 states in the long run.
Suppose now instead of p equals
q, that m is very, very large,
a very large number.
Let's take m going to infinity.
And suppose that the system
is on the stable side.
That means that
p is less than q,
which means that there's
a tendency for customers
to be served faster
than they arrive.
In other words, the chain is
drifting toward that direction.
So that means that
rho is less than 1
and what it means is that
this infinite series, when
m goes to infinity, is
the geometric series.
And this series is going
to be 1 over 1 minus rho.
That is, this infinite
series is 1 over 1 minus rho.
And since pi of 0 is 1
over this infinite series,
we end up having pi
0 equals 1 minus rho.
And since we have pi of i equals
pi 0 times rho at the power i,
we end up having that pi
of i equals pi of 0, which
is 1 minus rho times
rho at the power i,
for i equal-- this
pi i can be seen
as coming from the
probability distribution.
They tell us that if we observe
that chain at time-- let's
say one billion--
and ask-- where
is the state of
the Markov chain?
The answer will be the
chain is in state zero, that
is, the system is empty with
a probability 1 minus rho,
or there is one
customer in the system.
And that happens with
probability 1 minus rho times
rho.
And so on.
So the distribution
can be drawn like that.
You have here i corresponding to
a state and if you put pi of i
here, 0 here, then 1, 2, 3--
then pi of 0 is 1 minus rho
here.
pi of 1 will be rho times
1 minus rho and pi of 2
and so forth.
So if you look at this
distribution here,
it's pretty much a
geometric distribution,
except that it has shifted so
that it starts at 0 instead
of starting at 1.
So it's a shifted geometric.
This model is the first
and simplest model
that one encounters when
studying queuing theory.
So a final note--
the PMF that we
have here has an expected value.
And the expectation is
given here-- e of x of m
is-- let me rewrite it here--
it's rho over 1 minus rho.
And this formula-- which
is interesting to anyone
who tries to analyze a
system of this kind--
tells you the following-- that
as long as rho is less than 1,
then the expected number
of customers in the system
is finite.
But if rho, this little rho,
becomes very close to 1,
then you're going to have
1 over something that
is very close to 0.
And that number will
be very, very big.
So when rho becomes
very close to 1,
that means the load factor
is something like-- let's say
0.99-- you expect to have a
very large number of customers
in the system at any given time.